[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
[تصفيق]
القوات الروسيه تقترب من السيطره على بخمت
وبوتين يتوعد بالرد على كل تهديد للامن
القومي بكل الوسائل
المانيا تدعو لمنع ايران من امتلاك
القنبله النوويه واسرائيل تدعو لابقاء
الحل العسكري على الطاوله
حمله الاعتقالات في تونس تدخل اسبوعها
الثالث ودعوات للسلطات لتوضيح حيثيات قضيه
التامر على امن الدوله
وزلزال جديد في ولايه ملاطيا التركيه
يتسبب في مقتل شخصين واصابه 140 اخرين
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
معارك داري تخوضها القوات الروسيه للسيطره
على مدينه باخموت الاستراتيجيه حيث يزداد
الوضع صعوبه على القوات الاوكرانيه كما
تشير اخر المعلومات الميدانيه
الجيش الاوكراني اوضح ان الوضع متوتر جدا
حول باخموت وقال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الكسندرسكي ان الروس ارسلوا
الوحدات الاكثر جهوزيه في مجموعه فاغنير
التي تحاول اختراق الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
ومحاصره المدينه
وقد تمكنت القوات الروسيه من قطع ثلاثه من
الطرق الاربعه التي تسمح للاوكرانيين
بادخال الامدادات الى باخموت ولم يتبقى
متاحا سوى الطريق المؤدي الى الغرب باتجاه
والذي يحاول الروس التقدم نحوه من الجنوب
هذا وتعد المعارك في بخموت بمنطقه
الدوناتس شرق البلاد الاعنف منذ بدء
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه حيث تتعرض خطوط
الدفاع الاوكرانيه لقصف عنيف بسبب الهجوم
الروسي المتجدد وعلى الرغم من خضوع جزء من
المنطقه لسيطره الروس وحلفائهم
الانفصاليين الا ان بخمت ما زالت تحت
سيطره الاوكرانيين حتى الان هذا بالاضافه
الى مقاطعه خركيب الواقعه شمال شرق
اوكرانيا
ومدينتي ايزيوم واليمن التي استعادتهما
القوات الاوكرانيه من قبضه الجيش الروسي
اما المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره العسكريه
الروسيه في اقليم الدومبس فتشمل دونسك
ومع محاوله القوات الروسيه السيطره على
تلك المدينه الاستراتيجيه منذ اكثر من سته
اشهر يقول الرئيس الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه تدمر كل ما يمكن لحمايه مواقعها
بشكل مستمر
نقيب اوكراني تحدث عن وجود نقص في الذخيره
وخاصه قذائف المدفعيه وبعد ناقلات الجند
المدرعه لتحريك القوات
ورغم نقص الموارد ما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر على المدينه لان انسحاب
المدافعين عن باخموت سيؤدي الى تمهيد
الطريق لروسيا للدفع باتجاه مدن اكبر في
شرق اوكرانيا مثل كراماتورسك
[موسيقى]
ليت
الى دونيسكا حيث مراسل العربي يتابع انكتب
الاوضاع في بخموت رائد اهلا وسهلا بك موت
ثم باخموت ولا شيء غير باخمه الان اخر
المعلومات البدنيه رائد وهل باتت المدينه
تعتبر في حكم الساقطه عسكريا بالنسبه الى
الروس ام لا يمكن قول ذلك
مساء الخير
عزيزي بالفعل معارك مستعره هنا في المحور
الشرقي من
من اوكرانيا وفي المحور الشمالي من مقاطعه
بالفعل مدينه باخمت مستعره بالفعل
بالمعارك ما بين الطرفين ربما ان نقصد
ذخيره كما اسلفت عزيزي هو يعني السبب الذي
يجعل القوات الروسيه تتقدم نقصد ذخيره عند
الجانب الاوكراني بالفعل قوات فارنار دخلت
من اطراف المدينه الشماليه يوم امس في حي
احد الاحياء
ستوبينكا بالفعل دخلت واظهرت فيديوهات
للقوات الروسيه وهي يعني
تتحرك وتتقدم في شوارع داخل مدينه باخمت
كما ان المحور الجنوبي تقدمت منه القوات
ايضا ودخلت الى الاحياء السكنيه المحور
الشرقي يشهد معارك ايضا محتدمه وضاريه ما
بين جانبين في مناطق المصانع والمعامل
المحور الغربي هو الوحيد الذي بقي يعني
منفتحا امام الجيش الاوكراني اما للانسحاب
واما للامدادات العسكريه ان كان بالجنود
او بالذخيره تحاول قوات فاجنر التقدم طالب
ويعني توسيع الطوق من الناحيه الشماليه
الى الشماليه الغربيه هناك بلده تدعى
بغداد هذا بعد ان سيطرت القوات الروسيه
على بلده ياجدنايا وبريخوف كعده بلدات في
المحور الشمالي قبل ان تدخل الى بلده
ستوبكي وتتقدم لتوسيع الطوق اذا وصلت الى
بلده بغدانا كهذا يعني بان الطوق يكون
تقريبا قد اكتمل الا من ممرات يعني ضيقه
جدا هناك كما اسلفت هو الوحيد الذي يوصل
الامدادات العسكريه ربما في الفتره
الاخيره والقوات الروسيه قوات فاجنر
تحديدا تبعد كيلو متر واحد عن هذا الطريق
المشاهدين دائما
يسالون ما يعني هل يمكن الفصل بين قوات
فاجنير والقوات الروسيه ام لا يعني في هذه
المعركه لا يمكن الفصل بينهما وفي حال
سقطت
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالنسبه الى القوات
الروسيه ما هو الهدف التالي او المدينه
التاليه
للحديث عن اهميه مدينه باخم ربما مدينه
باقمت ليس لها اهميه كبيره من حيث يعني
الخيرات او بما يعني تكتنز هذه المدينه هي
عباره عن مناجم ملح يعني مصانع الكحول هذا
ما تمتاز بهذه المدينه ومن السكان لم
يتبقى الكثير من السكان ربما تم اجلاء
جميع السكان لكن هذه المدينه تعتبر
استراتيجيه بالدرجه الاولى لانها هي
البوابه للمدن الكبرى يعني نتحدث عن
كراماتورست نتحدث عن صلابيانس التي ما
زالت تحبس المياه يعني نهر سيفرسكانيه هو
خلف مدينه
سلافيانس تحجز المياه عن مقاطعه دانيت
باكملها كما ان مدينه قسطنطين وفكا في
الناحيه الجنوبيه من باخمط ايضا هي مدينه
هامه جدا هذه المدن الكبرى لو دخلت القوات
الروسيه الى باخمت لا كان لها هو الطريق
او البوابه الرئيسيه هذا من جانب لكن من
جانب اخر الفرق ما بين قوات باقنر والجيش
الروسي
الجيش الروسي هو جيش منظم تابع للدفاع
الروسيه قوات فاج هي مؤسسه شركه خاصه
وتعمل يعني
بدعم ربما
بالذخيره لكن ليس بالقياده من قبل الدفاع
الروسيه وهذا ما يجعل التبانات والتناقض
دائما ما بين
القدر منذ مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر شكرا
جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه
الى كيف الان موفد العربيه احمد باجاتو
يوافينا باخر التطورات احمد اهلا وسهلا بك
قبل ان اسالك عن وجهه النظر الاوكرانيه
حول تطورات المعركه في بخموت العواج منذ
قليل تحدثت عن انفجارات قويه في كييف اخر
المعلومات
نعم ليس صحيحا طالب يعني ما حدث هو حريق
وانفجار الاسطوانات الغاز ليس شيئا كبيرا
للغايه هكذا تقول الاداره المحليه اذا ليس
هناك انفجار كبير كما تحدثت بعض وسائل
الانباء لكن اذا تحدثنا عن بخموت وهي
المعركه الاهم والاكثر شراسه الان والتي
يتحدث عنها الجميع ليس فقط وسائل الاعلام
والقاده السياسيين وانما ايضا الروس
والاوكرانيا المواطنين يعني
قوات البريه يتحدث وايضا نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني عن ان الوضع صعب للغايه
بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه في بخمه الان
نظرا للشراسه الهجوميه التي تقوم بها قوات
فاجنر والتي يعني يعني تقدم النخبه من
قواتها لمهاجمه مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه
وايضا مدعومه بالطيران الحربي والمسيرات
وكذلك المدفعيه المدينه باتت شبه مدمره
بالكامل
المدينه التي كان بها اكثر من 7 من
المواطنين يوجد فيها الان اقل من الفين
مواطن الصور توضح بجلاء حجم الدمار الذي
طال هذه المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه
والقياده هنا تتحدث عن ان من 600 الى
من عسكري من قوات فاجنر يقتلون يوميا في
الهجمات التي تقودها او تقودها القوات
الروسيه مع قوات الاوكرانيه
لكن هذا لم يمنعهم التقدم وهم يريدون
السيطره على المدينه باي طريق باي طريق
كان وحتى اتحدث بانهم يتبعون اسلوب
الاستنزاف التام والتدمير الكامل للمدينه
يريدون السيطره عليها باي شكل كان حتى
يصلوا الى سفيان وكذلك ايضا كراماتورسك
اللتان يعني تسلم ايضا من القصف احيانا من
قبل المدفعيه والصواريخ الروسيه طيب نعم
ايضا هناك حديث عن انه مع اقتراب الربيع
سيكون من الصعب على اقوات فجنا للتقدم لان
الارض ستصبح طونيه وموحله سيكون صعب على
الاليات العسكريه الروسيه التقدم ما زالت
المطالب احمد انت انت وفق متابعتك
متابعتك سواء لتصريحات المسؤولين للاكراد
تحديدا الاوكرانيين تحديدا العسكريين وحتى
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه في كييف وفي غير
كياف هل
تتعامل السلطات الاوكرانيه مع معركه بخموت
على انها معركه خاسره
هم لا يتحدثون عنها انها معركه خاسره لكن
يقولون انهم يتراجعون يتراجعون ويصفون هذا
التراجع بالتراجع الظرفي والتكتيكي لا
يقولون انهم سيخسرون المدينه لكن هم
يقولون انهم يتراجعون هذا ما يقوله القاده
الاوكراني وبالفعل هم يقولون وضع صعب
للغايه على القوات الموجوده هناك ولذلك
يدفعون شيئا فشيئا به قوات اخرى لدعم
القوات الموجوده في هذه المدينه من ناحيه
الغربيه بالطبع لان يعني هناك محاوله
تطويق من الجانب الشمالي والجنوبي والشرقي
من جانب قوات فاجنر للقوات المتواجده هناك
تراجع بالفعل هذا لا يمكنه احد في بخموت
لكن هم لا يريدون هذا التراجع ان يكون
سريعا لانه اذا كان هذا التراجع سريعا
ستسقط ضخمت في النهايه في ايدي القوات
الروسيه ومن ثم سيكون الانطلاق الى مناطق
اكثر اخرى اكثر اهميه اهميه بخمه ليست
كبيره هي فقط اكتسبت اهميتها من كونها
باتت عصيه على الروس فتره طويله لذلك باتت
يعني ملء السنه والبصر الان لكنها ليست
بالاهميه التي يتم الحديث عنها لكن يعني
مساله كرامه الان بالنسبه للروس هذه
المدينه الصغيره التي لم يستطيعوا السيطره
عليها لمده اشهر منك يا مفرد العربيه احمد
نجاتو دائما احمد شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المتابعه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اقر بان
العام الماضي كان صعبا الا انه توعد بالرد
على كل تهديد للامن القومي بكل الوسائل
مشيرا الى ان وكالات الامن الروسيه نجحت
في احباط مخططات ارهابيه تستهدف الامن
القومي الروسي وقال بوتين خلال زيارته
لمقر الامن الفيدرالي الروسي ان اوكرانيا
تستخدم اساليب ارهابيه ولها تاريخ طويل في
ذلك
العام 2022 كان عاما صعبا في مواجهه
الارهاب قمتم بحمايه حدود روسيا واحباط
المخططات التي تستهدف امننا القومي جميعنا
نعرف ان كياب تستخدم اساليب ارهابيه ولها
تاريخ طويل في ذلك اشكر كل القاده والجنود
الذين يعملون في الصفوف الاماميه ووجهوا
ضربات قاسمه للعدو
هذا وجه رئيس الوكالات الامن بالعمل سريعا
في المناطق الجديده التي سيطرت عليها
روسيا في اوكرانيا والرد على التهديدات
بكل الوسائل كما شدد على اهميه مواصله دعم
القوات هناك بكل الاسلحه والذخائر وتقويه
وحدات الاستطلاع
لدينا اهداف اساسيه بشان العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وذلك يتطلب تبادل المعلومات سريعا
مع بقيه الاجهزه في المناطق الجديده
ومساعده المدنيين هناك ويجب ان تخضع
جميعها لسلطه وكاله الامن الفيدرالي وتدعم
قواتنا بكل الاسلحه والذخائر لتقويه وحدات
الاستطلاع وحمايه البيانات
الى موسكو لمزيد من المتابعه تنضم اليهم
هناك مراسله العربيه اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
المواقف والتصريحات تحديدا من وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قبل ان اسالك عن موضوع
المجال الجوي فوق
مرحبا طالب الدفاع الروسيه اليوم كانت قد
حذرت من امكانيه حدوث استفزازات باستخدام
مواد كيميائيه مشعه كانت قد سجلت وصولها
الى مناطق متاخمه لمدينه باخموت كانت قد
تحدثت عن وصول نحو 16 صندوق تحوي على مواد
معويه مصدرها كما قالت الدفاع الروسيه هي
وزاره عفوا هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وصلت الى هناك وسط وسط اتهامات كانت قد
وجهت الى موسكو في امكانيه استخدام موسكو
للسلاح الكيماوي هناك
الان تقول ان هناك امكانيه لاستخدام هذه
المواد الكيماويه كعمليه
في المناطق المجاوره لمدينه باخمت ومصدرها
طبعا هذه المواد التي وصلت ايضا مع قوات
اجنبيه كما قالت روسيا على سكه على محطه
او التي حملت على القطار الى الى مناطق
كما تحدثت في باك مود اما بخصوص كما ذكرت
حول الدفاع الجوي اغلاق المنطقه الجويه
فوق مدينه بطرسبرج التي تحدثت عليه عنها
منذ قليل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تحدثت انها قامت باجراء تدريبات فوق
المجال الجوي في مدينه بطرسبورغ
لمحاكاه عمليه لكشف وصدد الاجسام الغريبه
التي تدخل الاراضي الروسيه وطبعا هنا من
بينها المسيرات لذلك قامت باغلاق المجال
الجوي فوق مدينه بطرسبورغ لفتره معينه
ورفعت المقاتلات الى الجو وهذه العمليه
التي اجرتها هي بالتعاون بين الجيش القوات
الروسيه والقوات الطوارئ الروسيه ايضا
طبعا هذا بالتزامن مع هجمات وكانت واسعه
نطاق قد تعرضت لها الاراضي الروسيه اليوم
طالب من قبل مسيرات في اكثر من منطقه من
بينها ضواحي موسكو كانت عرضه منطقه تحتوي
على محطه غاز
لمسيره لم تؤدي طبعا الى سقوط ضحايا ولكن
هي اخترقت الاراضي الروسيه وليست هي المره
الاولى كما تعلم طالب
كاتيا هل يتعامل المسؤولون الروس مع معركه
بخموت على انها معركه منتهيه وان هذه
المدينه باتت بشكل او باخر تحت السيطره
الروسيه هذا واحد اثنين ما الذي يستشف
ايضا من مواقف الرئيس بوتين اليوم خصوصا
في المناطق التي حررتها القوات الروسيه
حسب يعني الكلام الروسي
بالفعل طالب روسيا ومن خلال التصريحات
الاخيره بالاخص من قبل الانفصاليين في كل
من دونسك
كانت تتحدث عن ان روسيا هي على بعد خطوات
من السيطره على مدينه
بسبب محاصرتها من الشمال والجنوب وبالاخص
كنا قد شهدنا انها تقوم بالسيطره في
الفتره الاخيره على مناطق متاخمه لها وقرى
متاخمه لمدينه كما تحدث الان اكثر من مره
انه تمت قطع الامدادات والاسلحه عن القوات
الاوكرانيه وانه لديهم قد يكون في
المستقبل خياران اما الفرار او البقاء
طبعا كاسرى داخل مدينه باخموت هذا من جانب
جانب الاخر كما قلت عن الرئيس الروسيان
اليوم كان قد تحدث الى هيكل او خلال
اجتماع مع جهاز الامن الفيدرالي وهو طبعا
من اهم الاجهزه التي تعمل الان بكثافه
خلال
السابقه بالاخص في عمليات صدر الاختراقات
من قبل الجانب الاوكراني والذي هو تحدث
بالتحديد عن اهميه تجديد الامن على الحدود
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وفي المناطق الجديده
التي سيطرت عليها روسيا مؤخرا في اوكرانيا
هو طالب جهاز الامن الفيدرالي بان يتم
السيطره عليه بشكل
شديد لمكافحه هجوم استخباراتي من قبل
الجانب الاوكراني او المجموعات التقريبيه
طيب ساكتفي بهذا القدر من موسكو مراسله
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتي على كل هذه
المتابعه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ايران تغلق مدارس للفتيات بعد تسمم متعمد
لمئات الطالبات
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه قالت وزيره خارجيه المانيا انا
لينا بيربوك انه لا تبرير منطقيا من
الناحيه المدنيه لاحدث تخصيب ايراني
لليورانيوم بنسبه 83%
وخلال مؤتمر الصحفي في برلين مع نظيرها
الاسرائيلي كوهين على ضروره منع طهران من
امتلاك قنبله نوويه معربه عن قلقها من
البرنامج النووي الايراني بدوره اكد وزير
خارجيه اسرائيل على ضروره ابقاء خيار الحل
العسكري ضد ايران على الطاوله معتبره ان
هناك خيارين بشان ايران اما تشديد
العقوبات او الحل العسكري
واضاف كوهين ان السبيل الوحيد لوقف التقدم
النووي الايراني هو عبر الضغط الدبلوماسي
والاقتصادي
واوضح انه طلب من المانيا تصنيف الحرس
الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه
السبيل الوحيد لوقف التقدم النووي
الايراني هو عبر الضغط الدبلوماسي
والاقتصادي المجتمع الدولي لا يجب ان يقبل
ابدا برنامج ايران النووي ويجب اجبارها
على الوفاء بالتزاماتها الدوليه وفقا
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه حان الوقت
لاتخاذ خطوات وافعال لمنع ايران من امتلاك
سلاح نووي كما طلبت من نظيره الالمانيه
تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه في
المانيا وتوسيع ذلك ليشمل اوروبا
ان
مي دار الاشهر الثلاث الماضيه اصيبت مئات
من تلميذات المدارس في ايران باعياء وتسمم
جراء ما يعتقد انها ابخره ضاره تتسرب الى
الفصول الدراسيه
ورغم محاوله المسؤولين الايرانيين ان كانت
تلك الحوادث الا انهم باتوا يؤكدون الان
بان تلك الهجمات متعمده وقد استهدفت نحو
30 مدرسه من جانبه قال وزير الصحه
الايراني ان التحقيقات ابهرت ان سما خفيفا
ادى لحدوث حالات تسمم بين الطالبات فيما
قال المتحدث باسم الصحه لان التسمم ليس
نتيجه فيروس لكن دون التطرق الى المزيد من
التفاصيل
على صعيد اخر نظمت مجموعه من المتقاعدين
الايرانيين في مدينه اراك وقفه احتجاجيه
امام مقر المحافظه المركزيه اعتراضا على
سوء الاحوال المعيشيه وعدم معالجه مشاكل
المتقاعدين في ظل ارتفاع معدلات التضخم في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
قال الممثل الامريكي الخاص للشؤون
الفلسطينيه هادي عمرو خلال جوله في بلده
حواره جنوب مدينه نابلس قال انما قام به
المستوطنون في البلده غير مقبول
وعبر الممثل الامريكي للشؤون الفلسطينيه
عن ادانته وقلقه من تصاعد اعمال العنف
العشوائيه من جانب المستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه كما دعا المكتب الامريكي للشؤون
الفلسطينيه بالقدس لمحاسبه وملاحقه
المسؤولين عن هجمات المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين وتعويض من فقدوا ممتلكاتهم
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقف قلند قال من
جهته اثناء جوله في حراسه امنيه مشدده
بشوارع قريه حواره الخاويه الى حد كبير
انه يتوقع اياما صعبه
وامر جالنت القوات الاسرائيليه بالاستعداد
لجميع التهديدات وزياده نشاطها هذا وذكرت
صحيفه
ان 22 خبيرا اسرائيليا في القانون الدولي
حذروا في رساله للنائب العام من ان افعال
المستوطنين في بلده حواره بالضفه الغربيه
ليله الماضيه يمكن ان ترقى الى مستوى
جرائم الحرب
معي من رام الله الان مراسل العربيه خالد
قاسم لمزيد من المتابعه خالد اهلا وسهلا
بك اخر المعلومات التي تاتيكم من بلده
حواره وهل عاد الاهالي الى ممتلكاتهم
المدمره والمحروقه املا حتى الساعه لم يعد
احد مخافه من اعتداءات جديده للمستوطنين
لا هي ليست مخافه هي فرد من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي بمنع فتح المحل التجاريه على
الشارع الرئيسي رغم ان معظمها تم احراقه
اول بالامس بعض المنازل غير صالحه للسكن
تم احراقها بالكامل ما زال الفلسطينيون في
حواره
يحاولنا التعافي من اثار هجوم المستوطنين
على ممتلكاتهم وخاصه على المحل التجاريه
على الشارع الرئيسي والمنازل المحاذيه او
القريبه من مستوطنه هاربراخا اضافه الى
حرق مركبات المواطنين بحسب التقديرات
الفلسطينيه اكثر من مليون دولار خسائر
الفلسطينيين في تلك المنطقه لكن بشكل عام
الاوضاع متوتره ولكن لاحداث هذا اليوم طيب
كيف يفهم تصريح وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي زار
قام بجوله امنيه في بعض شوارع حواره وقال
نتوقع اياما صعبه خالد كيف يفهم هذا
الكلام على المستوى الفلسطيني
يعني بحسب التصريحات الاسرائيليه
والمحللين سواء الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
هناك مخاوف اسرائيليه من اشتعال جبهات
اخرى غير جبهه الضفه الغربيه مثل
قدوم او اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه
اسرائيل وايضا امتداد اعمال العنف التي
يقوم بها المستوطنون
لتحدث في ابعد من حواره هذه الايام تقتصر
اعتداءات المستوطنين على رشق مركبات
الفلسطينيين على الطرق العامه ولا مفارق
الطرق ولكن الخشيه من ان يقدم المستوطنون
على هجمات جديده على منازل وقرى فلسطينيه
وخاصه ان هناك تشجيع من بعض اعضاء الحكومه
مثل سموتريتش وبنكفير الذين لم يدينوا
العمليه بل باركوها ايضا طيب بالنسبه الى
تصريحات الممثل الامريكي الخاص للشؤون
الفلسطينيه هذه عمرو اليوم هل حملت جديدا
تطمينات الى الجانب الفلسطيني وسمعنا نبره
امريكيه جديده خالد ام لا يهمني قول ذلك
ولكن البارز هو ايضا
قدوم هذه امر الى حوار هذه ربما اول مره
يحضر ممثل بهذا المستوى الامريكي الى
مناطق فلسطينيه حدثت فيها اعمال عنف
والتصريح بادانه
ما جرى هذا ايضا
لاقا ارتياحا لدى الفلسطينيين بان الاداره
الامريكيه
تقف ربما في منتصف الطريق بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وليس كما جرت العاده ان
تسجد بشكل عام اعمال العنف تم سجب
واستنكار ما قام به المستوطنون في حواره
ودعا ايضا لتقديمهم للمحاكمه كما دعا الى
تعويض
المتضررين من الفلسطينيين من رام الله
مراسل العربيه خالد قاسم دائما شكرا جزيلا
لك خالد على هذه المتابعه
دخلت حمله الاعتقالات في تونس اسبوعها
الثالث حيث اعتقلت الشرطه التونسيه مؤخرا
ثلاثه نشطاء بالحزب الجمهوري على خلفيه
دعوات على مواقع التواصل لاطلاق سراح
الامين العام للحزب عصام الشامي فيما اذنت
النيابه العموميه بالاحتفاظ بالقيادي
البارز في النهضه السيد الفرجاني
الارتباطه بقضيه انستالينجو للصناعه
المحتوى والتي يشتبه ايضا بتورط رئيس
الحركه راشد الغنوشي ورئيس الوزراء الاسبق
حمادي الجبالي فيها
كما اذن القضاء بالاحتفاظ بالقيادي السابق
في حركه تحيه تونس ووزير البيئه الاسبق
رياض المؤخر في قضيه تتعلق بشبهات فساد
مالي واداري
ياتي ذلك وسط تنديد احزاب المعارضه وفي
مقدمها حزب النهضه بما اعتبرته تصفيه
للخصوم السياسيه
وقد طالبت السلطات التونسيه بتوضيح حيثيات
المتورطين في التامر على امن الدوله
الى تونس لمزيد من المتابع ينضم اليه من
العاصمه مراسل العربيه وليد عبد الله وليد
اهلا وسهلا بك اخر اخبار الملاحقات
والتوقيفات والى اين تتجه الامور
مرحبا طالب هو يوم اخر من جلسات الاستنتاق
بقطبي مكافحه الارهاب لا تنتهي جلسه الا
لتبدا اخرى الايقافات تتوسع هناك حديث على
ان القائمه التي انطلقت بسبعه عشر شخصيه
موقوفه على ذمه هذه القضيه او متهمه على
الاقل في هذه القضيه توسعت لتتجاوز
الاربعين شخصيه في انتظار ايقافات قد تكون
من الحجم الكبير في الساعات وربما في هذه
الليله او غدا على اقصى تقدير وسط شحا في
المعلومه من الجوانب الرسميه التي اختارت
ان تتكلم على سير عمليه تحقيق لدى الفرق
الامنيه او ايضا عمليات الاستنطاق في قطب
مكافحه الارهاب من قبل القاضي التحقيق 17
يوما منذ الايقاف الاول لشخصيات المورثه
في هذه القضيه وقد تطول هذه الاجراءات بين
لقافات وايضا
تحقيقات واصدار بطاقات ايداع بالسجن على
خطوره هذه القضيه التي تعتبر الاخطر بعد
قضيه التسفير الى بؤر التوتر المورط فيها
قيادات من حركه النهضه اللافت ايضا هو ان
بعض المعطيات التي نستاقيها تؤكد تورد
جهات اجنبيه ست سفراء ثلاثه منهم الان
موجودون في تونس وثلاث سفراء سابقون قائم
بالاعمال في احدى سفارات وايضا مستشاره
سياسيه مورطون في هذه القضيه وفق
التحقيقات ووفق ما افصحت عنه هيئه الدفاع
عن الموقوفين في هذه القضيه هناك من يعتبر
ان السلطات اختارت عدم الخوض في هذه
القضيه وابدائها للراي العام نظرا
لخطورتها اولا ثم نظرا لضمان سريه الابحاث
ولكن تداعياتها اصبحت وفق تقدم التحقيقات
تمس جوانب اخرى لا تتعلق بتامر على امن
الدوله فقط وانما ايضا ملفات الفساد ملفات
الارهاب ملفات التسفير الى ارى توتر
وتخابر مع جهات اجنبيه وهذا ما نستشفه من
الايقافات الاخيره لنشطاء سياسيين لوزراء
السابقين لقيادات حركه النهضه على غرار
السيد الفرجاني العقل المدبر للجوانب
الامنيه لحركه النهضه وجهازها السري
العسكري ناهيك عن عدد كبير من ملفات
الفساد التي شهدتها البلاد طيله العشريه
الاخيره طالب فقط مازلنا ننتظر حتى ربما
تعلن السلطات او تخرج في ندوه صحفيه سواء
من النيابه العموميه او قطب بمكافحه
الارهاب او حتى من وزاره العدل على ذلك
التحقيقات وفق مصادرنا ما زالت مستمره الى
الان
لا لتشمل العشرات فقط
السياسي بعد هذه
التوقيفات والملاحقات مرشح الى مزيد من
التعزم والاستقطاب اما يجري يريح الساحه
التونسيه
نعم اذا رمنا الحديث عن المشهد السياسي
اليوم في تونس هناك موقف السلطات من
الناحيه الرسميه الرئيس قيس سعيد يقول لا
مجال الى العوده الى الوراء نحن ماذون في
انقاذ البلاد
وتمت عمليه الانتخابات في بدايه شهر مارس
او على الاقل في الثلث الاول منه سيتم
تركيز برلمان جديد لانكبا على الاشتغال
على الملفات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه هذا
من الناحيه الرسميه من الناحيه الشعبيه
هناك طلب للمحاسبه وطمانه الراي العام
خاصه وان الملفات والقضايا خطيره جدا في
ظل هذه الظرفيه الصعبه والماذومه سياسيا
واقتصاديا واجتماعيا ثم المعارضه تلوح
بالنزول مره اخرى طالب الى الشارع هي
نهايه هذا الاسبوع لمطالبه باطلاق سراح ما
تعتبره مساجين سياسيين في قضيه لا وجود
لها بل ومفبركه المنظمات الوطنيه هي
بدورها تعد العده للاعلان عن مبادرتها وفق
ال رباعي لانقاذ البلاد تصور للحلول
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه قبل
عرضه على الراي العام والرئيس قسم الذي
يصر بدوره على لفظ هذا ونرى منا تونس
مراسل العربيه وليد عبد الله شكرا لك على
هذه المتابعه
اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه عن
مقتل شخصين واصابه 140 اخرين جراء الزلزال
الذي ضرب ولايه ملاطيا ظهر امس حيث تسبب
الزلزال الذي بلغت شدته 5.6 درجات على
مقياس ريختر بانهيار 29 بنايه واستنفار
اكثر من 600 عنصر من فرق الانقاذ للبحث عن
عجينه تحت الانقاب التي تمكنت من انقاذ 32
شخصا حتى الان
اكد رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيين دينيس شمال
للعربيه ان بلاده تسعى لفتح محكمه دوليه
للتحقيق فيما وصفه بجرائم الحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وقال شمال ان ايران ساعدت
روسيا في ارتكاب هذه الجرائم
نتحدث عن فتح محكمه دوليه ضد العدوان
الروسي ضد السياسيين الروس الذين اصدروا
اوامر جنائيه مماثله نتحدث ايضا عن حقيقه
ان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تحقق بالفعل
في جرائم جنائيه وجرائم حرب لروسيا
وتحدثوا عن حقيقه ان ايران حليف او متواطئ
في جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها روسيا
بالتاكيد في اطار التحقيق الجنائي من
محكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كجزء من تحقيق
المحكمه العسكريه الدوليه سنتحدث عن حقيقه
ان ايران ساعدت روسيا في ارتكاب هذه
الجرائم
المقابله الكامله مع رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا
اجرتها الزميله ليال الاختيار وتحدث شمال
عن دعم دول الخليج الانسانيه والاقتصادي
لاوكرانيا كما تحدث عن العقوبات الجديده
التي تقترحها بلاده على روسيا المشاهدين
تتابعون المقابله كامله غدا في الرابعه
عصرا بتوقيت السابع بتوقيت السعوديه
اعربت الخارجيه الصينيه عن رفضها لقرار
البيت الابيض بشان حظر تطبيق تيك توك
وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره ان القراره
يعبر عن اجراءات قامعيه ضد الشركات
الاجنبيه ويتجاوز الامن القومي مشيرا الى
ان الصين ترفض القرار وتعارضه
يعارض بشده للنهج الخاطئه للجانب الامريكي
والمتمثله في ارهاق مفهوم الامن القومي
واساءه استخدام القوه الوطنيه وقمع شركات
البلدان الاخرى بشكل غير منطقي يجب على
الحكومه الامريكيه احترام مبادئ اقتصاد
السوق والمنافسه العادله وان تتوقف ايضا
عن قمع الشركات ذات الصله عليها ان توفر
بيئه مفتوحه وعادله وغيره تمييزيه للشركات
الاجنبيه حتى تستثمر وتعمل في الولايات
المتحده
وكان البيت الابيض قد امهل الهيئات
الحكوميه ثلاثين يوما للتاكد من عدم وجود
تطبيق تيك توك على اي من الاجهزه او
الانظمه التابعه للحكومه الاتحاديه وقالت
مديره مكتب الاداره والميزانيه
للجهات الحكوميه في مذكره توجيهيه انه
سيكون مطلوبا منها تعديل عقود تكنولوجيا
المعلومات للتاكد من ان المتعاقدين يحمون
بيانات الولايات المتحده من خلال وقف
استخدام تيك توك على الانظمه والاجهزه
المستخدمه في اطار عملهم
ساحه حرب مفتوحه بين امريكا والصين
اتهامات واسعه تطال تيك توك باستعماله
نمطين مختلفين من الخوارزميات التي تعتمد
على سلوكيات المشاهد والمحتوى بغض النظر
عن عدد متابعي الحساب الاولى داخل الصين
والتي تشجع المحتوى الجاد والثقافي والنمط
الثاني للعالم كله معتمدا على ترويج
المحتوى الترفيهي والرقصي والاغاني ولا
يتم توزيعه بشكل واسع اذا تم تصنيف
المحتوى على انه جاد رغم ان فيسبوك مازال
يتربى على عرشه منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بعدد مشتركين نشيطين يتجاوز مليارين و700
مليون شخص الا ان تيك توك وصل في فتره
قصيره جدا الى مليار ومئتين مليون مستخدم
النشط
اذهب الى واشنطن لمزيد من المتابعه
والتحليل ينضم الي من هناك الدكتور بول
مرقص وهو استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس
منظمه جستيسيا الحقوقيه اهلا وسهلا بك هل
مفهوم ومبرر بالنسبه اليك هذه القرارات
سواء الامريكيه او الكنديه ضد تيك توك
ولاحقا ربما القرارات الاوروبيه ضد هذه
المنصه ام لا ما يجري هو مجرد تصفيه
حسابات سياسيه امريكيه مع اكثر ولا اقل
طبعا هنا القانون الامريكي يجيز اتخاذ اي
قيود او انزال اي قيود حمايه للحريات
الشخصيه وللبيانات الشخصيه ايضا
ولحمايه الامريكيين
والمستخدمين هنا مستخدمين شبكه من اي
اختراق لمعلوماتهم الشخصيه الى ما هنالك
من قيود انما لكن الاطار الزمني الذي يحدث
فيه هذا الموضوع ياتي بعد مساله
المنطاد الصيني
والتعثر في العلاقه الامريكيه الصينيه
وبالتالي فان التوقيت هو توقيت سياسي على
الاقل انما القيود هي قيود قانونيه تلامس
تلامس التضييق يعني الحريه الشخصيه مصانع
هنا بمقتضى التعديل الدستوري لكن يمكن
للحكومه اتخاذ اجراءات ضروريه
ربما سيعترض البعض ويقول لك انه ما هو
يتعارض تماما مع المبدا الاساسي في الحريه
الشخصيه انه يكون واحد عنده تطبيق تيك توك
هنا السؤال يعني الولايات المتحده والغرب
تحديدا يعني ما جرى مع ار تي شبكه ار تي
او ما يجري الان مع تيك توك كانه يفهم انه
السياق السياسي يطغى على اي شيء اسمه حريه
يعني السياسه قبل الحريه حتى للمواطنين
الامريكيين هل هذا صحيح
ولذلك قلت ان
الطريق يلامس مبدا ضرب هذه الحريه يلامس
يعني الامر
موضوع هنا بسبب ان ثلث عدد الامريكيين
يتعاطون هذا التطبيق
والسوشيال ميديا بشكل عام والفيسبوك الى
ما هنالك مما يمكن
للصينيين اختراق بياناتهم الشخصيه بحاله
التيك توك وقد قال الصينيون انفسهم ان ذلك
يتعارض مع اقتصاد السوق والمنافسه العادله
الى ما هنالك لكن ايضا لا ننسى ان الاداره
الامريكيه توجهت بالقيود راهنا الى
الاجهزه الحكوميه وطلبت حذف هذا التطبيق
في مهله معينه حفاظا على الامن القومي
وعلى الخصوصيه المساله دقيقه جدا وشائكه
نعم وتحتمل هذه الاشكاليه القانونيه التي
تحدثت عنها يعني العلاقه الحريه والقيود
اذا ثبت فعلا ان ذلك من شانه المساس
بالحريه وبداه المعلومات والدخول الى
البيانات
وخرق
الامن ولا يتصل فقط بالظروف التي تحدثت
عنها الزمنيه فاننا نكون امام وسائل
قانونيه وليس تعد على الحريه البعض سيسال
ويقول لك هل بدات واشنطن بمعاقبه الصين
سياسيا نتيجه مواقفها تحديدا من الحرب في
اوكرانيا عبر يعني تنفيذ سله من العقوبات
بداتها الان بتطبيق تيك توك
دون شك
دون ان يعني
الاطار الزمني وبالتالي وقوع هذا الطريق
والقيود في يعني خضام التازم الامريكي
الصيني والعلاقات
الجافه جدا
والمتازمه لا يعني ينفك ولا يمكن ان يكون
بمنع عن انزال هذه القيود ولو كانت الع
لاقه عليه لما كنا ربما شاهدنا هذا
التوقيت مهم من واشنطن الدكتور بول مرقس
استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيسه منظمه
جوسيسيا الحقوقيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
وقفه احتجاجيه جنوب ايطاليا بعد غرق قارب
خشبي مقتض بالمهاجرين ومقتل جميع رك
وب
اهلا بكم من جديد معلومات استخباراتيه
جديده بشان منشا فيروس كورونا توصلت اليها
وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه مستنده الى خبرات
علميه معتبره صحيفه
نقلا عن البيت الابيض انه لا اجماع في
الاداره الامريكيه بشان مصدر كورونا بعد
رفض الحكومه الصينيه تقييما لوزاره الطاقه
الامريكيه يشير الى ان جائحه كورونا نشات
عن تسرب مخبري المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي افاد بوجود عدم
يقين واسع داخل الاداره بشان مصدر الفيروس
مشيرا الى ان الرئيس جو بايدن مصمم على
المكان الذي بدا منه الفيروس
في اشاره الى مدينه ووهان الصينيه
اقام سكان مدينه الواقعه جنوب ايطاليا
وقفه احتجاجيه على من لقوا حتفهم بعد ان
اصطدم قارب خشبي مقتظ بالمهاجرين بالشعاب
الصخريه لساحل
وبالتالي تحطمه والتسبب بمقتل 62 شخصا
وفقدان العشره
تستمر شكاوى سكان مدينه تعز اليمنيه بعد
ان باتت التلال القمامه في المدينه تهدد
بانتشار الامراض والاوبئه مع استمرار حصار
ميليشيا الحوثي للمدينه
الشلال الملون هذا عباره عن تلال من
القمامه التي تسكم الانوف وتهدد بانتشار
الامراض والاوبئه في مدينه تعز مدينه كانت
فيما مضى احدى اجمل مدن اليمن اختنا
امراض في الجهاز التنفسي امراض الرئه كذلك
تصيب الناس بالاحباط ولما تلفت قدامك وانت
ماشي في الشارع
ونقمامه ونقمامه الناموس
كثره الذباب
ميليشيا الحوثي تحاصير المدينه فتمنع
الجهات المحليه والدوليه من تقديم الدعم
والمساعده الامر الذي يهدد باثار كارثيه
على الخدمات الصحيه والبيئيه لمئات الالاف
من السكان الجهات المختصه
القائمه على مهمه النظافه هي اكثر
كانت اكثر موارده هي محليه من الرسوم
والضرائب من السلطات المحليه كان دعم من
منظمات المانحه التي
انسحبت منذ بدء الصراع في البلد
وبقيت في بعض مناطق لكن نشاطها بقي محدود
الا انها عادت تدريجيا في
محافظه عدن اللي هي العاصمه المؤقته حاليا
يسكنوا تعز نحو 600 الف نسمه وتتفاقم
معاناه الاهالي هناك بعد انسحاب جهات
داعمه لصندوق النظافه جراء المخاطر التي
تتعرض لها في ظل الحرب التي يشنها
الحوثيون في اليمن منذ سنوات
وفيما تستمر النفايات بالتراكم امام ابواب
البيوت مسببه الكثير من الامراض وبينها
حمى الضنك يحاول السكان ايجاد حلول بدائيه
لهذه الازمه
لها اشهر
عامله ثلاثه برامج ابنائي صار عندهم
اسهالات طرش
حمى الضناك انا نفسي اكثر من ثلاث مرات او
بحدود ثلاث مرات هكذا
تكدس النفايات في شوارع تعز وفي سلال
المهملات وكل ما قد ينشا عن هذا من امراض
للجهاز التنفسي لاسيما مع انتشار البعوض
حول اماكن النفايات يقابله احصاء لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه يقول ان مئات الاشخاص
توفوا جراء انتشار الكوليرا في المدينه
عقب اندلاع الحرب نور الحصن العربيه
الخامسه المفصله وفينكم بها من العربيه
تبقى تحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]